[Music]
it's time to put on a happy face and
it's not just a macho written in
lipstick on the mirror and Joker
what is how we feel on football Sundays
this is the B are betting show presented
by the Caesars Palace sports book
she is our betting insider Kelly Naomi
Stewart and I'm cabby Richards last
week's vets pets back after the bills
bus 7 we got this week started off right
hitting the over and the Rams see our
team on Thursday night I've got more
week 5 picks coming right up
[Music]
let's kick things off with the marquee
matchups of the week first off we got a
Sunday afternoon game in Jerry's
worldpackers plus three and a half of
the Cowboys total of 46 I'd love to lay
the points here with the pack with the
Cowboys I just can't do it
one seventeen and one as a non
divisional favorite after losing
straight-up and against the spread Oh
Green Bay we know their defense is real
they're rested but who are they
offensively
I'm lien here with the Cowboys on the
money line Sunday night Colts plus 11 at
the Chiefs total 56 guys we go over this
every single week
I cannot lay points here with this
Chiefs defense that back door is always
wide open plus double-digit home
favorites 13 28 and 1 during Sunday
Night Football I tried to make a case
here for the Colts because why they have
that playoff revenge from last season
but playoff revenge away underdogs are 7
and 21 against a spread since 2012
actually lean towards the under in this
one and Monday night the Browns puts
four and a half it's probably headed to
five at the 49ers total 47 tried to make
a case for the Niners but the last one
they covered as a whole favorite was
under Jim Harbaugh 7 in 17 against the
spread their last 24 home games coupled
with the fact that week 5 3 no teams
coming off a bye it's a real momentum
killer 12 and 23 against the spread
speaking of momentum I'm counting on
that Brown to keep that momentum after
that Ravens game going on Monday night I
like the Browns here let's quickly recap
the marquee matchups of the week
remember a lien it's not a game that I'm
personally betting this son having some
action that's the direction I'm leaning
towards got the Cowboys on the money
line the Colts cheats under 56 and I do
like the Browns on Monday night in his
new book talking to strangers Malcolm
Gladwell explains that the tools and the
strategies we use to make sense of our
friends
betrayus when we're talking to strangers
looking to pick three new winners this
week I try a new strategy it's talking
to Americans for the people's parlay
roses are red violets are blue the
people's parlay is on for this one need
some help from you I got you will you
help me my gosh first one is Carolina
versus Jackson Joe Carolina is the
favorite I gotta jump I hate to do this
but I gotta go with Jacksonville you
don't believe in Kyle Allen
I don't can't go wrong in the Panthers
the defense looking good right now we
got Ramsey we got no cam I'm taking
Jackson good man
take Jackson do for the Jags with
Minshew I like him man he's hot right
now can you shave this into a Gardner
Minshew
a handlebar mustache I'm going with
Jacksonville Jackson any particular
reason why cams out Jacksonville is
known for their defense great pass for
us I think that'd be good
the next game is Chicago versus Oakland
this game is being played in London
England
the Bears they're gonna they're gonna
come in and they're gonna whoop the
Raiders they're gonna whoop I'm gonna
thread East Chicago for sure I'm gonna
see bears
I still like Chicago giving true Biscay
Zout no-brainer a thousand on Oakland
let me see it Mary
he's just better pay me if I win I'm a
Golden Bears in London no home feel
there's nobody but that defense is
ridiculous buffalo vs Tennessee
Tennessee all the way I'm gonna have to
go with Tennessee I'll take the bills
you take the bill up sediment tie-ins oh
just just because our friends back home
that time span yeah Tennessee man for
sure the times ago win this one I feel
like it's because balance out and
Berkeley didn't love Jenna when I do win
the people's partly how should I
celebrate things oh yeah losing builds
character and I got about four times as
much character as anybody else Kelly
what do you think of our picks
finally some new teams and the people's
barley caviar I've got the Bears minus
five and a half the jacks with Serena
and the Titans minus three I got us a
cabby this kind of still looks like
another losing ticket I think you still
need better people and now why I don't
agree with all of those fix here are
some pics I do like first up I like the
Jets +14 this low total catching double
digits makes me really happy I
understand it's scary to bet on the Jets
darn old or not it doesn't matter we're
playing against Philly in a situational
sandwich spot Philly defeated Green Bay
and Lambeau Field they've got games with
Minnesota in Dallas on deck they just
got to beat this lonely little Jets team
down here by more than 14 I don't think
it's gonna happen
teams that scored 14 points are less
headed into their bye week by the way
the Jets scored 14 versus the Pats
are twenty seven eight and one coming
out of there by since 2009
I like the Jets here catching two
touchdowns next up we got the Cardinals
plus three at the bangles total of 47 I
know you guys are still really mad at me
from that bengals pick on Monday night
and I'm sorry three and oh right out of
the gate and that was all she wrote but
that ugly Monday night performance leads
us to some value here this line is just
a little too low oh by the way I saw
before the show started Caesars Palace
has only taken one Bengals moneyline bet
so might want to hop on that one I sure
did right before we got started plus the
cards have
covered a game in the Eastern time zone
nine of their last ten tries the Bengals
will capitalize against a bag Cardinals
team here bangles - three next up I got
a favorite I actually have two -
favorites now Vikings - five and a half
of the Giants total 43 and a half it is
very very rare that I lay points on the
road it's one of my things I very rarely
do and that's how much I like this
Vikings team the giant part of public
underdog they benefited off six
turnovers in their last two games
Minnesota eight and all against the
spread versus divisional opponents
coming off a loss under my favorite
favorite coach Mike Zimmer and why
because he covers numbers Vikings get it
done in MetLife last but not least the
Falcons this one opened at five now down
to four at the Texans total of 50 it's
good it's good news for us I like that
reverse line movement money coming out
Atlanta why because they've out gained
their opponents in every single game
they have the number 10 offense in 6.2
yards per play but they have the number
27 office and points per game they
cannot find the endzone how are they
going to find the end zone against that
Texans secondary plus I can't lay points
with Bill O'Brien he's 5 and 13 straight
up against offenses an average 375 or
more yards per game Falcons and don't
forget to sprinkle that one on the money
line the last time the Falcons played in
Houston the setting was that historic
Super Bowl collapse of 28 he wrapped
that he got pulled over with 55 grand in
his pocket on his new track double XL on
his new album Kirk if the baby put all
that 55 on the Falcons against the
Patriots in Super Bowl 51 listen I'll
let him tell you in this week's betting
confessional what they do is the baby
and I'm here with BR betting
I actually bet on that Super Bowl yeah
Atlanta was up in the fourth quarter and
the Brady came down I really placed the
bet and what he was already losing and
I'm like I bet you will come back
like he'd like to say he got an
automatic not here it's a bang I was
talking big - I was like the better like
$10,000 but I'm like man we lose the
time he had it you know I mean so I kept
it a little friendly I think I I I swear
to god I was talking 10k like a baby bet
on the goat well done my dude you can
check out baby's new out but the baby's
new album Kirk wherever you stream your
music it is now time for minds of the
public where Kelly will answer vetting
questions sent to us from our Prudential
report audience and up first Derrek Lee
wants to know how long does it take you
to decide on a bet for one game and
what's the process like one game oh it's
hard to bring it down to just one game
and what I spent on each and every
single game but I would say I probably
spent 20 to 30 hours a week the hard
part is the math right guys and I just
don't have the time doing all the media
stuff anymore so there's really good
power ratings out there that you can
adjust from there then I break things
down situation I'm always looking for
turns and angles to back up my plays as
well don't let the number of school you
ask is there a set amount of games you
have action on each week like this many
on Saturday this many on Sunday and
since you love taking the underdogs what
are your thoughts on Tampa Bay versus
the same yeah you know it varies week to
week I may have 15 plays on the Saturday
6 on a Sunday I don't limit myself to oh
I've already got 11 plays I can't bet
any more than that so I would say it's
more comes down to your bankroll and how
much when I'm allowed where I allow
myself monetarily to bet each week as
far as the Bucs
ssandsk oh man the Bucs look a headline
with 7 prior to them beating their Rams
and the Saints beating the Cowboys I
feel like a lot of that value is gone
it's already dropped from three and a
half to three I do like the reverse live
movement I do like the Bucs but at this
point in time there's just no play for
me Mitch David says how much of your
selections are influenced by historic
metrics for against the spread and then
how much by the eye test and current
information
now you know a lot of those all come
into play I think the eye test though
for me is the least important for
example on Friday as I give my dad a
call my dad loves to tell me oh but I
watched this team every single week and
their office is gonna face up with this
defense at the end of the day it really
does come down to the numbers
historic metrics are my favorite as I
mentioned the last segment why do I love
coach Zimmer cuz he covers the sprite
and I think those things are important
when we see those coaches go that extra
mile for their backers those are the
guys I like nice ok with math and mind
telling let's make the public some more
money let's stack those stacks it's time
for Kelly's best bet that's right it's
time for my best bet we cashed last week
with the bills plus Senate we're now
three and one on the season that
Redskins loser week 2 still gets me you
know whatever loser still gets me the
Broncos last week minus three over the
Jags they blew that lead but I'm going
back to the well with the Broncos again
this week AFC West Division again this -
or this oh and four Broncos team should
be two and two they blew the game to the
Bears they blew the game to the Jags
this Chargers team is way too back
banged up to be laying this many points
in a soccer stadium that they have no
home-field advantage
the line is the same as last year and
what happened Vance Joseph and the
donkeys waltz in there and got the W
chargers - and seven against the spread
their last nine games as a whole
favorite yeah I wanted to make this a
four unit place so bad you guys I played
this at six and a half the Bronco is now
down to five and a half they're headed
to five so jump on board
you guys ready to recap all of my picks
for week five all right these are listed
in order of confidence on how many units
I would recommend you bet on each we
have three units on the Broncos Vikings
and Jets now remember a unit is a
standard bet amount and should be 1% of
your bankroll we also have two units on
the Falcons the
bangles and the Browns the rare a couple
of favorites in this week's picks I know
I had to change it up a little bit bills
are how much I like those favorites that
should be a nice sign for you guys at
home thank you for joining us on this
week's be our bedding show presented by
the Caesars Palace sportsbook our
journey continues on social ad vir
underscore bedding fall along to check
my pics and yours we'll see you guys
next week
[Music]
[Music]